[Musique]
ce perso et cauchemardesque mais
vraiment et bien bienvenue à tous pour
passer une mauvaise nuit j'espère vous
regardez cette vidéo le soir si c'est
pas le cas metella oppose revenait à 23h
et fait plaignent à 23h ok on fait comme
ça personne ne va le faire trois
histoires d'horreur vrai épisode 454 car
le concept marche bien j'ai lu pas mal
d'histoires d'horreur ces derniers temps
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup je vous avoue
en plus moi et ayant joué à des jeux
d'horreur je le rappelle je suis pas
forcément très sensible à certaines
histoires donc c'est compliqué de me
faire vraiment flippé à avec juste un
texte écrit mais j'ai trouvé des choses
très bas dans il ya toujours une
mécanique précisément qui me fait
flipper qui me donne des frissons et que
je déteste c'est la fameuse intrusion
par intrusion je veux dire intrusion
chez quelqu'un donc quelqu'un qui vient
chez toi alors que c'est chez toi et que
tu sais pas qui c'est et il est là cette
mécanique là ça me fait vraiment flipper
il ya deux histoires qui traite de ça et
une autre qui traite d'autres choses
temps quand une maintenant bref
messieurs dames
installez vous confortablement dans
votre lit éteignez les lumières et un
long si hélas si j'étais à youtube et un
stylet y aurait une intro dédié à ce
type de vidéos
première histoire très courte bâtisse
vit à new york il habite au deuxième
étage d'un immeuble qui fait juste trois
étages il est donc au milieu ils ont un
vide sanitaire qui connecte du coup ces
trois appartements entre petits schémas
à l'appui approximatif
il explique que ni lui ni ses voisins ne
savent réellement pourquoi cette pièce
existe et quels intérêts elle a
finalement mais qu'en tout cas aucun
d'eux niva et aucun d'eux ne l'utilisent
vous vous sentez le problème arrivait
avec cette pièce fut surtout un soir
bâtisse rentrer chez lui il arrive dans
son salon et y voit une femme debout sur
son escalier de secours qui regarde par
la fenêtre on est à new york à new york
il ya des escaliers issues de secours au
cas où il ya un feu et du coup quand tu
empruntes ses escaliers battu passe
devant la fenêtre des gens cette femme
est donc là debout a regardé par la
vitre et c'est quand même bizarre parce
qu'il faisait encore jour et surtout
comment il a fait pour arriver sur ses
escaliers de secours en bas vous savez
il ya une échelle sur un rail qui
s'amène vers le sol et bref la réussit
elle s'est démerdé aller là on sait pas
trop comment mais on se doute que du
coup ses intentions ne sont pas
incroyablement bienveillante
c'est le moins que nous puissions dire
baptiste s'est jetée par terre et s'est
mis à ramper pour atteindre son
téléphone tout en regardant la femme qui
était sur les escaliers et qui essayait
de trouver un moyen d'ouvrir les
fenêtres de baptiste ça y est j'ai peur
c'est officiel je regardais baptiste a
enfin pu aller dans sa chambre pour
choper son téléphone et pour appeler le
propriétaire de l'appartement afin
qu'ils appellent la police et qui une
enquête sur ce à quoi à prayssas
baptiste est retourné dans son salon
pour voir si elle était encore là et
n'ont aucun visuel mais d'un coup il a
entendu un gros bruit qui venait de son
plafond il explique que son plafond
c'est un plafond fait en dalles de liège
vous savez c'est les trucs qu'on peut
soulever et décale si les plafonds les
moins rassurant du monde qu'on se le
dise après avoir entendu du bruit venir
de là haut il a donc regardé ce qui se
passait là d'où venait le bruit et la
vue une dalle se soulevaient être décalé
sur le côté et il a vu le reflet de la
lumière dans ce qui s'apparentait à être
deux yeux dans le noir des bruits
il explique alors qu'il n'a aucune idée
de comment elle a fait pour atteindre le
fameux vide sanitaire mais qu'il a chopé
un balai et qu'il a commencé à taper
dans tout les dalle de son
plafond et après un autre long moment il
a arrêté il a compris qu'elle n'était
plus là et il s'est décidé du coup a
appelé lui même la police à leur dire de
rappliquer en vitesse pour enquêter mais
malheureusement ça n'a rien donné les
flics sont venus ils ont checké les
chambres le salon le vide sanitaire le
faux-plafond l'issue de secours et ça
n'a rien donné mais batista eu des news
quelques jours plus tard de la police
puisqu'il longtemps
dans les escaliers de secours d'un autre
appartement très proche de celle ils ont
dit que c'était en fait une personne qui
se droguait et qu'elle avait été
extrêmement violente à leur égard quand
ils ont voulu l'arrêter baptiste
explique qu'il est bien content qu'ils
avaient été choqués mais qui sait pas si
c'était vraiment elle dans son faux
plafonds ou pas donc ça se trouve la
personne qui était dans son faux plafond
est toujours en totale liberté y as
c'est bon vous êtes prêt à passer aux
vraies histoires terribles maintenant
vous êtes sûr vous êtes prêt je vous
laisse deux secondes pour réfléchir
on y va l'uci a rencontré comme beaucoup
de filles un mec sur till there qui lui
plaît ils sont parlés pendant plusieurs
semaines sans se voir en vrai et ils ont
même découvert qu'ils avaient quelques
amis en commun ce qui est un truc plutôt
rassurant quand tu rencontres quelqu'un
sur steam d'or finalement tu dis bon on
a quand même des connexions indirects
donc logiquement je risque pas de me
faire tuer par cette personne si tu
prends le cas extrêmes
lucie explique un soir elle était un peu
en déprime et là-bas envie de voir
quelqu'un elle a donc appelé un hubert
elle a décidé d'aller chez ce mec qui
s'appelle team
une fois sur place ils ont commencé par
discuter devant la maison ensemble et
lussier a trouvé que le courant passait
encore mieux en vrai elle était ravie
n'est ce pas trop parfait comme début
d'histoire à lui a notamment parlé de
ses problèmes de santé et ça a beaucoup
touché team étant donné que sa soeur est
décédée et qu'elle avait une maladie
proche de celle de lucie ce détail a son
importance
est ce donc rentré dans la maison et en
entrant première remarque de lucie la
maison ressemblait en gros une sorte
d'unité de stockage mec plein de trucs
partout très encombré team l'a alors
emmené dans sa chambre pour m'expliquer
senchim vous connaissez ils sont posés
dans l'île ont parlé pendant pas mal de
temps la soirée se finit est normalement
et tout deux s'endorment dans le lit de
steam et elle a aucune remarque spécial
à faire à part que c'était un peu
féminin comme déco etc
mais bon tu sais ce qu'il vaut mais
alors où ça cloche le cac attendez
attendez qu'elle se réveille le six se
réveille vers 10 heures du matin à cause
d'une horrible odeurs elle explique que
sa santé comme s'il y avait mille rats
décédée sous le plancher de la maison la
nuit étant passée l'uci n'avait plus
d'alcool dans ce sens elle avait
totalement des cuvées elle avait donc un
meilleur sens de l'observation esma
regarder autour d'elle et elle remarque
que dans la penderie il n'y a que des
vêtements de filles
elle va d'abord se dire que tim a une
copine et que c'est les fringues de sa
copine et que du coup il a trompé sa
meuf avec elle et c'est chaud elle s'est
alors assis sur le lit et elle a regardé
l'oreiller sur lequel elle venait de
passer la nuit et elle constate qu'il
n'y avait pas de thé d'oreiller sur
l'oreiller et que surtout il y avait du
sang du vieux sang séché comme si
quelqu'un avait tous et du sang sur son
oreiller en pleine nuit et c'est là
qu'elle a une sorte de
clic elle a vu les vêtements de filles
dans la penderie elle se souvient le
team lui a parlé de sa soeur qui était
décédé d'une maladie eureka elle
comprend qu'elle est probablement dans
la chambre de la soeur de steam
elle lui demande alors avec délicatesse
s'ils viennent de dormir dans la chambre
de sa soeur ou pas et il lui répond que
oui c'est bel et bien la chambre de sa
soeur et qu'il n'a rien changé ni lavé
depuis qu'elle est décédé et que c'est
l'endroit où elle est décédée dans ses
bras et il explique ensuite à lucie
qu'elle lui rappelle énormément sa soeur
qu'il est vraiment vraiment amoureux
d'elle là ça commençait très creepy lui
explique qu'elle se sentait très triste
pour lui que ce mec-là a dû traverser un
truc terrible mais qu'elle pouvait pas
rester là quoi qu'il fallait qu'elle
qu'elle s'en aille
c'était trop pour elle elle rentre chez
elle elle décide de ne pas couper les
ponts elles gardent contact il parle
encore un petit peu et après quelques
semaines elle relance pour x raisons
l'application find my friends c'est une
application qui permet de géolocaliser
tes amis elle lance la pluie elle
remarque un truc horrible sa location à
elle a été partagée avec tim la nuit où
elle a dormi chez lui qui veut
clairement dire que tim pendant qu'elle
dormait a pris son téléphone et a activé
sa dans l'appli elle a alors appelé team
pour lui expliquer sa découverte
et pour lui dire qu'elle voulait plus
lui parler que ce genre de comportement
c'est juste pas possible et c'est là que
team a complètement changé de
personnalité et qui s'est mis à vouloir
la faire complètement culpabiliser qui
s'est mis à dire des trucs du style
non mais tu peux pas croire que j'ai
fait ça c'est des bêtises tu es vraiment
une qui me jette juste parce
que mon chat est mort récemment
alors voilà c'était l'histoire de lucie
et de ti sacré prince charmant et
c'était quoi cette odeur et ce qui l'a
buté son chat est ce qu'il a séquestrée
on sait pas qui c'est glauque on
n'aura jamais la réponse et j'espère
qu'on croisera jamais changement alors
les amis il est maintenant temps de
passer à la troisième histoire celle où
y'a gigamedia instruction laissez moi
vous raconter l'histoire de mathilde
marié à valentin depuis plusieurs années
assurez-vous valentin est un homme
charmant et très correcte et le truc
creepy ne vient pas de lui mathilde est
tombé malade ce genre grosse maladie qui
la cloue au lit et valentin voulu
qu'elle prenne du repos pour se remettre
de cette maladie ça rend toujours triste
quand tu vois ton mec ou ta meuf qui est
trop mal à cause d'une maladie lui
souhaite le meilleur tu veux qu'ils se
rétablissent donc voila tu le pouponne
un peu les parents de mathilde voulant
voir leur petit fils valentin s'est
rendu chez eux avec le bébé et a donc
laissé matile se reposer tranquillement
à la maison quelques heures plus tard
matt il se réveille parce qu'elle a des
douleurs à la poitrine parce qu'elle
doit à l'été et évacué à la soie le
dilemme du comme tu as envie de faire
pipi en pleine nuit ou tôt le matin ag
lafley me suis tellement bien là mais
faut que j'aie à et je pourrai pas
dormir tant que je vais pas ouais mais
j'ai la flemme
mais la version poitrine qui fait mal
donc je me pense que c'est encore plus
désagréable
après je n'en sais rien vous en douter
au bout d'un petit moment elle commence
à être bien réveillé elle se rend compte
qu'il fait très froid dans la maison
elle ouvre les yeux et elle entend la
porte d'entrée se ferme et elle est donc
contente parce qu'elle se dit plus tard
hier je me réveille au moment où
valentin rentrer c'est cool elle appelle
alors valentin et 0 réponse elle allume
la lumière de la chambre la une la
lumière de la cuisine elle allume tout
cas lumière qu'elle peut allumer pour
vérifier qu'elle est bien seul et il ya
personne dans la maison elle tchèque
c'est la porte d'entrée verrouillé la
porte d'entrée verrouillé bref tout va
bien j'ai peur elle sait que c'était pas
un rêve donc elle envoie un message à
valentin pour lui dire j'ai peur
il s'est passé un truc bizarre peut-on
après valence à rentrer elle lui
explique de vive voix ils mangent et
valentin reste dans le salon pour dormir
avec le bébé alors que mathilde elle
dort dans la chambre
tout simplement pour que matt il puisse
faire une nuit correct pour qu'elle
puisse se reposer vraiment parce qu'un
bébé comme vous le savez ça pleure elle
a clairement pas besoin de ça vu comme
elle est malade avant de dormir valentin
s'assure que la porte d'entrée fermée ça
sur toutes les fenêtres sont bien
verrouillées et chacun va se coucher
maths il se réveille vers 2 heures du
matin à nouveau parce que elle doit
extraire al amal et elle ressent la même
chose que quelques heures avant qu'elle
s'est réveillée et qu'elle n'était pas
bien pas à l'aise du tout et elle voit
une silhouette au bord de son lit
quelqu'un est là au pied du lit et y
fait la même taille et la même
corpulence que valentin son mari est lui
demande donc d'aller lui chercher un
verre d'eau pendant qu'elles se
préparent à évacuer mais valentin reste
immobile et nuit répond pas elle lui
redemande donc d'aller lui chercher un
verre d'eau et valentin lui répond alors
non non rendors toi j'aime bien te
regarder dormir
sauf que ce n'est pas la voix de 20 en
maths il se rue sur sa lampe de chevet
pour l'allumer et elle voit un mec
parfait
disney a rigolé française non n'essaie
pas de vaincu la peur par le nsa d'un
jeu rapporte valentin entend le rire ça
le réveil il couronne va t-il dans la
chambre et malheureusement le mec a
réussi à prendre la fuite avant même que
valentin arrive dans la chambre mathilde
et valentin ont donc tout de suite
appelé la police étant à laitages la
chambre avait quand même pas mal
ôtez ils n'ont pas réussi à comprendre
comment le mec a fait pour venir et
aussi pour partir sans se blesser en
ayant sauté cette hauteur bref y'a eu
investigations et quelques années après
ça n'a toujours rien donné et sont
jamais retrouvés
ce mec qui continue probablement à faire
ça dans le quartier en gros match et a
rencontré un mec qui adore s'introduire
chez les gens en cachette et regarder
les femmes dormir c'est bon pour vous
c'est que le mans badens vous imaginez
le traumatisme que tu te prend dans la
gueule quand tu vis ça c'est horrible
c'est la fin les amis de ce troisième
épisode des trois histoires terrifiantes
je sais ça vous a plu on en fait tous
les mois voilà c'est le petit rythme
qu'on a ça me plaît ça me permet
d'attendre qui est vraiment des
histoires cool a raconté par des trucs
pas ouf je vous dis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo un peu moins flippant ne
vous en faites pas je vous souhaite une
très bonne une excellente nuit vraiment
fermé bien les yeux regardez pas au pied
de vos clichés où vous réveiller en
pleine nuit ne regardez pas à bientôt
tout le monde
bonne nuit
[Musique]